letztes jahr ja schon irgendwie probiert
da irgendwas zu machen und versucht
hereinzukommen das nicht funktioniert
dieses jahr stehen die karten eventuell
ein bisschen besser
das kind sondern wir kommen zu der frage
was mich spielen wieder interne optimal
den besten modus den spd gibt übrigens
wenn ihr lust hat auf eine in time woche
wenn ihr bock hat auf so eine interne
woche dann schreibt das gerne meine
kommentare der gedanke kam mir gerade
eben hat sich um sowie ein bisschen
gespielt haben
damit bleibt offen ob jetzt kann ich
gebrauchen
die teilnehmer wurden aber mehr leute
ich kann gar nicht mehr bewusst
entscheiden ob jetzt behindert reden
will oder nicht das ist eben diesen
automatismus das geht von selbst das
geht von der fwg ihre auf gelernt haben
kennt ihr jetzt werden eure kinder
laufen lernen
es ist so schallte mal okay gut ich
wollte euch heute was sagen und zwar
wollte ich euch sagen dass ich dumm bin
mit einkaufen ein ich wollte euch sagen
dass eine sache die ich relativ geil
wind finden würde und die sicher auch
ein paar von euch gefallen würde nicht
ganz unwahrscheinlich ist bioethanol
damage porschen übertreiben die leggins
der film kommt gelaunt genannt
dankeschön
was ich sagen wollte back to topic es
gibt hier nicht eine sache wo von könnt
ihr die sache sein
ihr habt sicher mitbekommen in den
letzten tagen ist viel von war die rede
und ich will euch jetzt nicht zu viel
versprechen aber von meinem jetzigen
kenntnisstand aus ist es nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich dass ich dieses jahr
bei war u3 dabei sein kann ist er ist
nicht speziell nein ohne witz dass wir
einfach wer schon crazy aber wie gesagt
ich habe auch überlegt ob ich das jetzt
eine video schon an sprechen bevor alles
so endgültig feststeht
aber ich wollte ich einfach mal ein
bisschen auf dem laufenden halten
es ist noch nicht alles entschieden ist
kann auch sein dass es nicht klappt aber
momentan stehen die chancen nicht so
super schlecht also ich will seit ich
will jetzt nicht zu viel verraten
es könnte sein es kann aber auch gut
nicht sein aber für den fall dass es
klappen sollte schreibt mal gerne in die
kommentare rhein mit wem ihr euch mich
in einem team vorstellen könnte
wer könnte zu mir passen so als
teampartner klar so die üblichen
verdächtigen so maxfeld der leider flach
aber wer sonst außer max wer wird euch
einfach spontan ich habe mir das mal die
kommentare das würd mich interessieren
vor allem auch gerne so ungewöhnliche
kombination vielleicht leute mit denen
ich bisher überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte
wer auch mal ganz nah ist ok hat auch
die allerdings die alle ganzen ziemlich
begehrt dieses gefühl
schreibt mir das mal rein so du kommst
mir die treppe hoch genau genau so
machen wir das hat er mich nicht gesehen
hat mich wirklich nicht gesehen man
krass alter alte schwede hat er mich
noch richtig gut erwischt man halt
wieder ist das gestorben wäre gestorben
ich wäre verstauben in der luft w v und
die nacht vorgefallen sowie die augen
von karl kamer wer eine coole sache oder
was man hier so hoch war womit mir ich
sag euch falls ich da rein komme werde
ich mich auf jeden fall so geisteskrank
vorbereiten
das sei jetzt schon gesagt ich habe
jetzt diesen ganzen sommer quasi frei
ich habe jetzt am samstag dieser woche
also übermorgen meine letzte klausur
mitte nicht sterben ok danke
und dann habe ich quasi den ganzen
sommer frei ich nehme zwar an seinem
kollegen kurs teil seiner fortbildung
aber die geht auch nur 20 stunden pro
woche
das heißt ich hab dann relativ die zeit
außenrum werde auch noch da eine coole
sache starten da gebe ich aber noch
bescheid da wird diesen sommer einiges
gehen unter anderem auf einer anderen
plattform der vielleicht schon kennt
welche könnte das sein erwartet diesmal
erwartet auf welcher plattform ich in
diesem raum r mehr machen könnte ja das
jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen
gespoilert getier zähler vor zu viel
ich darf die alles ausplaudern vor allem
nicht wenn du nicht alles feststeht wie
gesagt noch mal zum thema wo ist steht
noch nicht fest aber es könnte sein also
es gibt indizien dass es eventuell
klappen könnte aber ich bin überhaupt
nicht eingeweihten dem prozess und
deswegen sag ich jetzt mal nicht zu viel
aber ich wollte irgendwie drüber reden
so weil es einfach krass ist ich habe
letztes jahr schon irgendwie probiert da
irgendwas zu machen und versucht da
reinzukommen das nicht funktioniert
dieses jahr stehen die karten eventuell
ein bisschen besser wie gesagt
und ja das wäre auf jeden fall neue
sphären heißt stellt euch es vor was es
in varel
wäre es nicht ein mit dem könnte es
themen
kennt ihr einen teampartner wie eine
fluglinie die teams trennt team per ok
aber das kann ich nicht mehr reinpacken
aber es tut mir sehr leid dass es nicht
mehr rein passt für showbiz in alter
schwede man für üben schon ein bisschen
fast draufgehen für war heute ein
bisschen straight und das hat nicht so
gut funktioniert man nein warum hatte
die allergien leiden eisen jasper
speziellen begnügen hier und da kommt
direkt der nächste am ellbogen ja komm
her du pc nein du bleibst weg von mir
genau mein junge bleib ecke und
musikkapellen sowie butter
bei der den trank oder neffen es diese
weg lauferei ist immer suspekt da müsst
ihr müsst ihr aufpassen wenn leute so
weg von euch dabei angucken dann müsse
immer aufpassen führen was im schilde
entweder an trank oder also hätte es
schon vier frauen so ewig viele kann
eigentlich mehr haben euro
ich habe auch nicht mehr so viele leben
gehabt anfang mai ist kriegt man viel
habe ich noch ein fall
ok hinterher das gute ist man keinen
fall wenn der senat nice dann kann man
auch sprinten immer versucht zu
schiessen war natürlich kein fehler drin
is ja leute so viel jetzt so von meiner
seite
wahrscheinlich macht von den bewährten
endlich gefallen hat und schreibt eure
vorschläge für mögliche teampartner und
fällt dann schon mögliche stöckling
namen in die kommentare
zwar sei es zu wissen wir sehen uns
wieder haut rein macht